we found this story on vogue.com about
alyssa
bertrand and she's a mom of six who
upcycles thrift store finds and alyssa
elisa excuse me
takes clothes bed sheets tablecloths and
curtains and turns them into insanely
cool children's clothing and then she
posts it all on her instagram account
je bella fleur that's french for flower
and i am a lifelong vintage store
enthusiast i really mean it my
housewares my clothes
all my life so i really took a shine to
her and her work
and now she's here to tell us about it
please welcome alisa bertrand
so excited to be here oh i'm so thrilled
okay
i am not kidding your work is
exquisite no wonder vogue is all over it
it looks
vogue level you have thank you kids tell
us about your
models so yes i'm a mom of six
but on my page jabella floor you see my
three younger girls which is
jayla jada and ella and i design for
them because i still think it's cool and
fun to hang with mom
and take pictures and get on a move
i mean this really is like if this was
in the pages of vogue i would not bat
an eye it's really amazing what you are
doing
and i heard that you liked going to
vintage thrift stores rather than buying
in regular stores
uh why is that well it started because
i mean i always wanted to be a fashion
designer but couldn't afford
you know the name brands and the logos
and plus i couldn't find like prints
that i like
and i'm all about prints and definitely
florals more the merrier
um so i just started repurposing and
thrifting and finding what i like to
recreate for the girls
what is your trick to photography
because honestly
it's not these are not iphone pics you
might i don't know what you're taking
them on but
they just look really elevated it is an
iphone it's an xr
that's what i have i mean i'm keeping it
simple
it's an art and i really am am amazed at
what you're doing now what are your top
three
thrifting tips please okay so
first if you see it and you like it
buy it because it might not be there
next time and that's a hard one to learn
um second is just go in and don't expect
to find something if you're looking for
like a jimi hendrix
and you look through 100 shirts and you
didn't find it you're gonna probably
come out with something else
you know and still be okay and then
third
just go in and search for you and what
you like
and what makes you feel good rather than
you going to a department store and it's
being set up
try something new what's a four dollar
shirt that has patterns when you're a
neutral person
try it because the best thing is is you
know when you start thrifting
it's it's fun and it can be extremely
rewarding
i totally agree as a lifelong thrifter
and vintage collector
myself i just always find things i could
never find in a store and i must say
your clothes and pictures are no
different they're unique and one of a
kind and we totally celebrate you
thank you elisa for being here thank you
so much for coming on the show
[Music]
you